[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is
Anthony Hayek and today I will be
talking about extensible AI with h2o
Google cloud platform and coop flow you
can ask questions any time on the
platform and we have Google's on standby
to answer them let's get started so
today we'll be talking about extensible
AI and I'll be presenting this first
portion with the Nick Punk so we wanted
to make distributed portable machine
learning on kubernetes easy for people
to deploy develop and manage those
installations and this is something we
set out as the mission for coop flow
with containers and container
deployments we had a similar problem
that we overcame in 2014 when we
developed kubernetes we wanted to
standardize the API so that people could
develop and manage these deployments
much simpler however even with as easy
as kubernetes makes container
deployments installing machine learning
on kubernetes isn't that easy you would
first have to become an expert in all of
these areas containers packaging
persistent volume scaling GPUs cloud API
etc in Turku flow coop flow was
developed to make this easier so that
everyone yes everyone could develop
distributed portable machine learning on
containers and kubernetes so a
deployment like this where you had a
works
workflow life cycle on the left side and
these clusters on the right side then
becomes replaced by a kubernetes
installation an abstraction of coop flow
and then you're able to do development
on your laptop locally you're able to
train on your own Prem cluster and you
can also deploy in the cloud so with
that I will hand it over to the node and
Nick to give us an introduction to h2o
de I and what they've done with coop
flow
who's that - or are they I we are a
Silicon Valley funded company we've been
in existence for about six years now for
in 2012 our investors are belts program
media and Nexus and park seon we are
team up about 90 AI experts including
far the top world's top grandmasters and
data scientists we have multiple
products most books nurse for h2 open
source machine learning platform which
is used by over 14,000 organizations and
HT travel sei which is our automated
machine learning platform we are
headquartered in Mountain View right
across the street and we have a global
presence including London prod in India
most recently pitched was named as a
leader in the 2018 Gartner data science
and magic machine learning Magic
Quadrant
beavin name was a leader but the most
completeness of vision we also
recognized for our quasi industry
standard as a demand of mine share among
machine learning platforms lot of the
machine learning frameworks you see do
use H - open source under the hood issue
customers also gave us the highest
overall score amongst all vendors for
sales success and support in the h-2a
product suite we have multiple lines we
have the h2o open source also known as
h2o core that's the in memory superior
machine learning platform we have
sparkling water which is h2o running on
top of top of apache spark and h2o for
GPU which is basically our machine
learning algorithm supported over to run
on GPUs they're all hundred-person
open-source and Apache 2 license built
for data scientists we have interfaces
in R and Python really easy to pick up
and learn and h2o flow which is of an
interactive notebook interface we offer
enterprise support for those softwares
on the right you see our commercial
enterprise offering called as travel as
AI where we essentially do automatic
feature in machine learning
interpretability
it's a commercial license software it's
built for domain users analyst data
scientist and business users it has a
full GUI based interface for end-to-end
machine learning and data science
so let's talk about H two or three first
or rope it says platform what is H 2 O
so H 2 is essentially a map platform
which provides basically an open source
and memory PR engine that provides a
whole bunch of paralyzed and distributed
algorithms popular ones like GLM random
forests G BMD planning etc it's also an
API written in Java so that programmers
can take advantage of it inside their
applications it has it's a very
lightweight install it can work on any
environment where basic Java environment
is supported and it's built for big data
you can build a lots of models with it
and you can use as much data as you have
without sampling so there are rhythms in
h2o if you take a look at it for a
second we cover the most commonly used
machine learning algorithms including
statistical algorithms like linear
models nabis ensemble tree methods like
random forests
graining boosted machines and we also
have a bunch of stacking and super
learner algorithms Bolton we also
support deep learning deep neural
networks including auto-encoders people
on your networks etc on the right you
see a bunch of unsurprised learning
algorithms including clustering methods
my k-means we you also support
dimensionality reduction or techniques
like PCA and generalized low rank models
we also have NLP supported through word
toufic and time series algorithm called
I Sykes in addition all of our
algorithms do have wide variety of hyper
parameter to parameter stay tuned for we
offer a list early stopping and an auto
ml functionality so that you can tune
through all the different algorithms and
get an ensemble of the best models so if
we take a look for a minute at the
typical Enterprise machine learning
workflow you have data typically sitting
in different silos they are all being
brought together and after you perform
some kind of ETL operation the data
quality and transformation techniques
are then applied on it then you have
what you call a modeling ready data
frame where you do feature engineering
which which is often which can often
mean transformation of your existing
features into better features that are
more adaptable for machine learning
algorithms
after that you then typically spend your
time doing machine learning including
triangle different logarithms and you
have final model artifact so does hto
fit into this workflow so with h2o you
can ingest data from a wide variety of
data sources including most common on on
primont cloud data sources so if your
data sitting in HDFS or Google Cloud
Storage for example or any other
database we can put data in to the
different connectors that we support
once data is brought into h2o then it's
basically converted into a distributed
key-value store that's Tetch to a data
frame once data is and there you can
apply a whole bunch of exploratory
techniques feature engineering and model
building algorithms all of which are
fully paralyzed and distributed and
that's the platform for the user they
can use this through this REST API which
supports which in turn lets you use
through R or Python or h2o flow or if
your programmer you can directly work
from Java Scala but for the end user
it's all fully abstracted DC and single
h2 a frame where they can operate on and
apply all these different techniques
once you run through all the different
models then you can essentially export
the model as a POJO as a mojo which are
basically Java artifacts that
encapsulate an entire model and these
artifacts are ready to go into
production you can deploy them into a
streaming environment put it in put them
in like a serverless architecture lab
architecture if you want or you can take
the code and embed into any application
that you might have so how does that fit
into the cupola paradigm so typically in
a store you might spin up a bunch of
machines bare metal machines and how
create initiative cluster where you run
their ship models instead of doing that
if you had to use Q as an abstraction
layer below the bare metal about the
bare metal and the h2o well that lets
you do is essentially a team of data
scientists can all share the same view
flow and kubernetes instant
cluster to create multiple h2o clusters
and these clusters can all be running in
parallel so multiple data centers can
spin up H to a cluster do their jobs
submit their workloads and then turn it
off and
keep doing that it also allows you to
scale up if you want to for example if
your workloads increase you can have
more nodes added to their underlying
kubernetes a coop globe cluster this can
obviously run on top of cloud or on prep
now let's get to driverless AI which is
of a commercial branch my software what
does driverless see I do
driverless AI delivers an expert data
service in the Box what we did is we
created an expert AI system which is
built by the world's most top Catalan
masters and AI experts and the goal was
to empower companies to accomplish and
to in machine learning and data science
with a single platform it performs a
work of a data scientist in the sense
that it does all the feature engineering
and model me actually is that an expert
data scientist would perform and gives
you a really highly accurate model which
is ready to go to production we also use
a lot of different visualization
techniques and interpretability
techniques to help understand the
results that are created from the model
so that you have we can build trust in
your model so if you take a look at the
typical intra- machine winning workflow
that we saw earlier what travel assayer
does now is it it automates the entire
workflow from the point when you have
the data frame ready so feature
engineering model building deployment
and repeatability they're all taken care
of by jealousy I so from data ingest to
protection we automated the entire route
and it's of course an award-winning
software which one that InfoWorld
technology they over Year award so wine
is travela CI a game-changer for
enterprises right so if you think about
the three common problems for enterprise
air adoption it's the lack of AI talent
there's a serious sort of experienced
expert data scientists it takes a lot of
time for data scientists even the ones
who are trained and experienced to build
models I can take anywhere from weeks to
days to do all these models and the
models they build are often black box
models which are really tough to
interpret so businesses have a tough
time trusting these models in production
so what do we do with driver CI is
essentially solved all these three
problems by offering digital data
scientists essentially data centers in a
box we automate the entire machine
learning workflow using GPS radio
machine learning so that the time to
pull the model goes from weeks to ow
so we are drastically reducing the time
taken and finally we do offer
explanations and interpretations for all
the models that we build in raveloe say
I so that helps build trust and
transparency so you can put these models
into production knowing how and why a
reflection was being made so when we
look at travel SEI how well do we
perform
we took the we took travel as a as a
task by letting it perform participate
in some of these cattle competitions and
what he found is that out of the box
Rolla see a comes in the top 5% out in
most competitions and in some
competitions it does come in the top 1%
out and if you look at the people who
beat Dallas yet they all the data
scientist experts
took days and weeks of work whereas
Dallas area was able to match their
performance in a matter of hours so it
provides this automatic feature
engineering model building to give you
the most accuracy for models so what
kind of feature engineering do we
perform right very quickly if you look
at it I know Nick is gonna cover that in
a demo in a little bit but essentially
we are doing things like automatic text
handling frequency encoding cross
validated target encoding truncated as
sweety clustering these are things that
experience and expertise and s would do
time and again to help improve the
accuracy of their models you apply the
feature imaging then do model building
and then see which features came out as
significant and you do this iteratively
and that's what growling our automates
it goes through the entire process it
radially and gives you the power of an
experience data scientist and finally
let's talk a minute about the deployment
whether it be H 2 O 3 all travel SEM we
always offer full deployment options
every model will didn't either h2 or I
will say I comes with the artifact Java
artifact it's either approach or module
file that can that's ready to go into
production these artifacts are built for
a low latency inferencing so we are able
to do sub second sub millisecond
inferencing and these models can then be
deployed in two different environments
they can be put into the on the cloud or
an Prem
put it put it behind a REST API service
so your applications can take advantage
of it so we go from the entire lifecycle
model training management and deployment
and that's a BRABUS point or two unique
here's
here's a quick demo on on some of the
products that we have running on cue
flow so as you can see on the left hand
side we have just a quick repo this is
what this is the work that we've been
doing between Google's cue flow team as
well as h2l and on the right hand side
we have a terminal window that's open to
our to our Cuban earnings master
instance which is connected to a couple
kubernetes slaves so if you take a look
here I can do cube CTL get nodes and
it'll tell me that I have the master as
well as two slaves connected and ready
and and if you do cube CTL describe
nodes you can see just exactly what is
available on each so you have the amount
of memory you have the number of pods
max pods available as number of CPUs per
node and you can see that there are
three nodes attached so the first thing
that we're going to run through is just
a quick demo of driverless AI which is
our enterprise platform so if you take a
look here KS component like oh sorry
list LS components you can take a see
that there's a couple different
components here the first one is
driverless and that's the component that
we're going to deploy now because
driverless AI is an enterprise platform
I've pre deployed it so that I can add a
license and we can use it so if we do
cubed CTL get pods you actually take a
look and see that driverless AI is
running right here so the first thing
that we're gonna do is so since its pre
deployed I already have it right here
basically this is driveless AI and the
GUI that comes associated with it there
are a couple different methods to ingest
data Google Cloud storage and bigquery
have pre-built integration connectors
and if we use Google Cloud Storage we
can actually just go straight to our
public demo data and import the data set
that we want so the data set that's
being imported is called credit card
train it's basically a did it data set
for a credit card company from China and
they
the target that we're predicting is
default next month so it's a
classification problem if we click
predict from here you can go to the
experiment GUI which is right here so if
you were to click experiments this is
what you would get after selecting a
data set and we want to select the
target column as default payment now we
do have a couple knobs tuning knobs to
tune for accuracy time and
interpretability and if we just sit go
it'll start the experiment from from
here you can actually see that the
experiment is running and while this is
going we'll go ahead and take a look at
the other parts of our hub our demo and
if I take a look at less at the actual
components within it you can see
components here environments which is
just a namespace area where you can have
different locations of where the
deployments are so you could have say an
environment for cloud or on Prem
the components are the important part
the components if you LS components is
going to show you all the different
components that are available to us
right now so I only I have driverless AI
which is deployed as are available as a
driverless J sonic component and I have
h2o static which is the h2o three
cluster available as a another component
as well these are made available through
the repo so if you take a look here
under h2o cube flow you can see so
there's the driverless package h2o
scaling which is a prototype and a co
static which is the standard cluster
that we have and if I do KSP kg list we
can actually see these are the available
packages that have been added here if
you have seen the cube flow repo it's
github.com /q flow I believe you can
actually see that the best way to import
or install a package would be KS pkg
install and then the registry name which
is just the
the file name right here h2o cute blow
slash since I already have the other
ones installed I'll just install h2o 3 -
scaling so as you can see it's installed
and if I do kiss pkg list again you can
see that now there's another Asterix
basically saying that it's been
installed
now I've pre-baked a couple of the
components which is why you're able to
see them here but if I were to use KS
prototype type use IO dot case on it dot
pkg dot H 2 O 3 static and we'll rename
this something else H 2 O 3 demo slash
and then add the necessary parameters
namespace we'll just call this default
and then here's where you want to add
some parameters so how much memory do
you want to give the cluster or rather
each node in the cluster how many CPUs
do you want to give each node in the
cluster since this is a a toy component
since I already have the other one
pre-baked we'll just give it one gig of
memory this is not recommended by the
way CPU just give it one CPU and number
of replicas so number of replicas being
the number of a number of nodes that you
want in the H 2 O 3 cluster so we can
name this 4 it doesn't really matter for
this specific component the important
thing is the model server image and this
one is going to be just the repo or the
docker hub repo under which you've
stored the docker image that is going to
be deployed so in this case you can
actually look back in the repo it does
exist docker files and any of the docker
files are available here for you to
build and and host on one of the docker
hub on your docker hub break up or or
another location locally h2o three keep
low
typos do exist model server image there
we go and basically what that does is it
creates a component so now if I go LS
components again you'll see that now
there's H 2 O 3 demo as well as
driverless as well as H 2 O 3 static now
I did pre deploy driverless AI because
it is a licensed product so we wanted to
make sure to be able to show the product
without the license you know being shown
so if I do cubes CTL get pods you'll
actually see that driverless exec
driverless AI is actually already
running and is already existing and if I
do cube CTL describe pod driver let's
say you can actually see we've allocated
a certain amount of memory no GPUs for
this just because the slaves did not
have GPUs to start with but driverless
AI is optimized for GPUs and actually
runs about 5x faster so definitely
recommended use GPUs so this is the
driverless AI GUI so this is what you
get when you attach to the to the
kubernetes instance through Q plop now
you can ingest data through a couple
different ways there's a built in
connectors to Google cloud storage as
well as Google bigquery will use Google
Cloud Storage for now h2o GCS public
data demo data
GIH 200 says i'll become I did on this
Shh
it's just tryin refresh in here um I
believe there's some networking to OGC
us there we go demo data there we go so
I'm just gonna import this is a basic
trade data set that we use it's called
the credit card data set basically it
has it has credit card data to predict
whether or not you're going to default
in the next month and well I run through
the rest of the demos I'm going to
actually run this in the background so
that we can get an idea of what it looks
like at the end so basically all you
have to do is click predict and just and
basically select which column you want
to do the prediction on if you have a
validation data set which we do we can
add that toggle which score you want as
well as some tuners as to how long you
wanted to take how accurate or rather
what weight you have for accuracy as
compared to interpretability and click
run now while this is running I'm
actually going to go through the quick
deployment of H 2 O 3 so if we take
again a look at components we can see
that there is the H 2 O 3 static JSON it
available and from here the package is
easy right
if we cat Parham or components params
you can actually take a look we've we
have all the parameters set up pre-baked
so once you have a component set up you
actually can just deploy this wherever
and however you want in whatever
namespace you want in whichever
environment you want available through
connecting redirecting the connection to
cube CTL so you can configure cube CTL
to connect to your on-prem resources run
a couple experiments then connect to the
cloud in GCE or DC p2 to run your on
cloud experiments as well so from here
all we have to do is because the
component is already pre already set up
here KS apply
default - see for the component that we
want and we'll go H 2 O 3 static now it
takes just a second what you can see is
it's actually creating a service which
is predefined as well as the deployments
necessary to to run H 2 O 3 and and
create the cluster now this one had a
cluster of 3 set up with two CPUs per
node as well as 6 gigabytes memory per
node
now it's generally recommended that you
have about 4 X amount of memory for the
amount of data that you want so if
you're using a gig of data then you
probably want about 4 gigs of data or
memory available so that the hto a3
cluster can do all the things that needs
to do so cute and now if we take a look
you see TL get pods again you'll see
that now there are a couple deployments
here and looks like we're having demo
bugs
or not yeah like it pods
there we go uh false alarm
it seems like so now if we look at the
services get SPC you can actually take a
look and we have an available node
balancer that is forwarding the the port
that we expose five four three two one
two and another available port that we
can then connect to so if we then attach
to the kubernetes master here and then
the port that we need we can see now
this is this is basically h2o flow it's
one of the options for running h2o as
well as you can run through either
through our or through python
interpreters basically this gives us a
much more point and click method of
ingesting data as well as as performing
machine learning practice our machine
learning experiments the the difference
being is that you can just click import
files or click get frames or click you
know predict and it will actually do it
will give you its it the code is all
self baked and all you really have to do
is just add some small parameters rather
than writing in R or Python so you don't
necessarily need to know those languages
now if you were interested in using
Python then there is the Python client
and you and and I've pre spawned a
Jupiter notebook basically all you have
to do is import h2o so this is this has
to be installed locally and from in from
h2o you can do from h2o out well import
h2o to ml and this is just one of the
packages auto ml is basically a package
that will run a very in-depth grid
search across multiple different
algorithms in order to find the ones
that are most effective essentially
across your data so from here now that
we've actually imported h2o and you can
actually take a look through H
to a flow here if I do admin and get
cluster status you can see that there's
actually three notes attached and you
can see some available memory which is
the amount of memory that I've allocated
previously and will actually see this in
the once I connect here as well so h2o
dot in net port is equal to and I'm just
gonna have to copy-paste the port again
or rather the IP and the port which is
this one right here
oh there we go
so basically this is pre-baked it's just
called the issue a cluster but this can
be renamed as you can see again three
nodes the total free memory which should
aggregate too close to eighteen but
there's a small drop off because you
want to not use the maximum keep memory
for h03 because it's written in Java so
Java actually gives us or takes away
about ten percent for itself to run so
at this point you're connected and you
can do basically the same thing as you
could do in h2o flow but just with with
with a Python interpreter so you can do
trained is equal to h2o dot import file
which would be able to get you your data
if you pass it from GCS there was there
is a GCS connector now this is um this
is an open source product so the GCS
connector is actually built by an
external party from what I had heard and
is getting merge soon but you know
there's the also as three connectors as
well as from local source and and and
most anywhere as long as it's openly
available for 4h do to connect and grab
so let's at the moment unfortunately
there was a minor bug that we were
dealing with previous to this just this
morning so I haven't been able to import
any data but we can take a quick look
back at our experiment which should have
finished already validation set is
missing oh so it seems the validation
set that that's here doesn't have the
necessary column so we're actually just
gonna have to rerun or we can rerun the
experiment but we can go and describe
this really quick while we're going
through it so just a quick understanding
a little bit more about what's going on
here is that there's a couple tuning
knobs basically accuracy which is how
do you want to rate accuracy so 10 would
be the highest one would be the least
and the model itself will actually be
built based on this so if you said low
accuracy it's gonna prioritize running
quicker it's gonna prioritize making
making a more simple model time is also
somewhat dependent on the other but
basically meaning if you allow it 10 for
time it means you don't mind it running
forever or not forever but for a much
longer time and that you're probably
likely preferring more complex models
and more higher accuracy so that's what
driverless AI will will prioritize and
finally there's interpretability
interpretability is essentially the
difference between say having a stacked
ensemble model of ten extra boost models
or maybe one or the idea being the
difference between having a neural net
or a linear regression so linear
regressions obviously being more
interpretable so that would be if you're
interpretability was ten versus one
might be something more complicated and
neural net or a stacked ensemble of
several extra boost models so you can
actually see what's going on here so
right now we have a couple different
charts but basically this just shows you
know how much lift you're gaining your
precision versus recall because this is
the classification your ROC curve and
this is across the number of epochs just
how are just the performance that the
machine is outputting against your
validation data so because our
validation data set was missing a column
it's actually going to just do cross
validation splits so you're basically
taking a section out of the the training
data set and running on each iteration
that as the as the validation or the the
validation scores so that's what we're
seeing here it's not just taking the
data set and training yourself on it
over and over so what's really cool here
is the variable importance and this is
something that I've been note
highlighted earlier essentially what it
is is that you can see a couple columns
which are like pay
this is actually a column that exists in
the normal data set but there's also
other data sets like CVT paid pay 1
which is the cross validated validated
target encoding for that specific column
which of I believe that's actually pay
10 excuse me so that's the cross
validated targeting coding of the column
pay 10 so the difference is is that one
was actually generated by the model and
by driverless AI itself versus pay 1
which was something that just came along
with the with the data set and since
this is very small data set it seems to
Train fairly quickly and once it
completes it will actually train a final
model that can be output as a mojo or
POJO so we can actually wait for that to
go since it's gonna finish in just a
second and the last thing is after this
is trained you can actually run em Li
MLA stands for machine learning
interpretability and what it does is it
basically takes your more complex model
if you were to say have an accuracy of
10 and an interpretability of 1 you can
actually take that model afterwards and
it'll run several the equivalent of like
several linear regressions to match what
the the more complex XD boost model is
doing under the hood so that you can
actually see what's going on see the
reasoning in the decision-making behind
our more complex model for in many cases
like certain verticals like financial
the financial vertical this would be
very important so from here you can
actually see so this would be Emily if
you click to interpret this model it'll
actually start interpreting it I can
actually close that well it's running so
this is MLI is running right now and we
can actually just go back to the
experiment and take a look so this is
where you might want to download an
experiment summary download some logs if
you build the Mojo scoring pipeline this
or the python scoring pipeline which
would be pojo this is where you would
get the the deployment that you would be
able to deploy quite probably the best
place would be in the cloud or and on
kubernetes where it's scalable so to
to demand and and you could use it to
make predictions so it looks like we're
running out of time so I think stay
tuned for a live Q&A we'll be back in
less than a minute
you
and welcome back with our QA so the
first question is what machine learning
platforms can run on cue flow and is it
limited to tensorflow the answer is no
it's not limited to tensorflow in fact I
believe in the cue flow repo there's
there's several different packages
already there as well
inclusive cafe caracaras I believe as
well as tensorflow
for deep learning with machine learning
this is this is what h2o does and we're
running on cue flow right now so so
that's that's probably I would say there
there's a lot of opportunities right
here h2o is been leveraging it for you
know the better of a couple months since
we started the partnership and it seems
to run fairly well so yeah hco3 as
another option for machine learning on
cue flow so the next question is can I
run coop flow on Prem absolutely that
was part of the design around something
that was portable and just for
distributed machine learning you can run
it on Prem you can run it on your laptop
via mini cube you can run it in the
cloud anywhere you have kubernetes the
goal is to be able to run goop flow the
next question we have is what is the
security privacy compliance for coop
flow running on the cloud is this any
different than running a VM there are no
additional security or privacy concerns
that coop flow opens up so any of the
same container or VM concerns that you
have these are going to maintain those
those concerns are going to stay the
same when you use coop flow and the last
question we have is can I use GPU TPU
with cube flow running on GCP absolutely
you can use both GPUs or you can use TP
use whichever you need for the work that
you need to get done to the performance
or the accuracy that you're after GPUs
and CPUs are available for those cases
actually if I could elaborate once more
on question number two so running on
from four with key flow one of the
things that we are currently working on
a
prototype if you will with the cute flow
team is actually the opportunity to do
bursty cloud which would mean that you
start on Prem with say four machines or
three machines or however many and if
your demand does exceed the the amount
of or the amount of resources available
on Prem then you can actually just spin
up another machine that will be on GC P
so either through G through GCE and it
will attach itself to the kubernetes
cluster and then act as a new resource
for the for the the kubernetes cluster
and then basically it be a first-class
citizen for being spun down ultimately
once the once the resources load is
reduced so that's that's actually
something we're working on we actually
have a couple scripts that are on the HT
OQ flow repo that are kind of the
prototypes of this and and they will
continue to be updated you know as time
progresses yeah absolutely burst a cloud
enables dynamic capacity increased
decrease as your workload needs it yeah
so that's it for QA I guess stay tuned
for the next session 99 problems but GPU
ain't one
you